fifteen years ago after much contentious
debate South Carolina came together in a
bipartisan way to move the flag from
atop the Capitol dome today we are here
in a moment of unity in our state
without ill will to say it's time to
move the flag from the capitol grounds
150 years after the end of the Civil War
the time has come there will be some in
our state who see this as a sad moment I
respect that but know this for good and
for bad whether it is on the Statehouse
grounds or in a museum the flag will
always be a part of the soil of South
Carolina but this is a moment in which
we could say that that flag while an
integral part of our past does not
represent the future of our great state
we know that bringing down the
Confederate flag will not bring back the
nine consoles that were taken from us
nor rid us of the hate and bigotry that
drove a monster through the doors of
mother Emanuel that night some divisions
are bigger than a flag the evil we saw
last Wednesday comes from a place much
deeper much darker but we are not going
to allow this symbol to divide us any
longer the fact that people are choosing
to use it as a sign of hate is something
that we cannot stand the fact that it
causes pain to so many is enough to move
it from the capitol grounds it is after
all a Capitol that belongs to all of us